all right Vivian is in Arizona - welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave and
radial thanks so much for taking my car
sure what's up um so Dave I just wanted
to securitize my husband and I married
five years ago I have no stood mom but
my husband had about 45,000 didn't loan
and now because he's not paying yet it's
gone up to about 60 and I'm just trying
to get him to start paying but he just
won't I don't know why he won't tell me
what do I do
okay so what other debts you guys have
yeah so thankfully my husband does not
use credit card and I don't have any
critical I've never I moved here from
Asia so and I've never had a credit card
so um that's that's something new to me
anyway so we have no death our cars are
all paid off
so noodle oh yeah and and you asked L
know
Point Blank I yeah I asked there's the
thing is the degree that he got is not
using it just job is his shop he has
always had so he's not actually using
that degree for and it's not I mean II
just he's not using that degreaser and
I'm wondering maybe that's it
I don't know why he won't pay off at
that so you haven't asked him I asked
him but he just won't say anything he
just says well I'll get to it I'll get
to it never gets down too much yeah okay
well and there's a couple of things that
I just hear in your language is you know
his that mind it like you know the way
you're phrasing things is that it's it's
not this cohesive team process that you
guys are using to talk about your money
are you guys on a budget together no I
want to set a budget but he just want I
want to start saving to forrester buy a
house but if you want I have you know
trying to reason with him as my putting
teeth and he's an American his Bouldin
brought his American yes yes yes and his
white I'm Asian and I learned I quickly
found that bottom
and is not always equal smart darlin
Total Money Makeover and Rachel I'm
reading smart money smart kids right now
and we I have two stepkids from him and
I'm also trying to work with them about
the exam okay so what is your house what
does he make a year and what do you make
a year
right now I'm a stay-at-home mom I was
working as an office manager before and
so right now I'm a stay-at-home wanna
finish my dress babies wind up I'm gonna
go back to work he makes about forty
three thousand a year and I am very very
frugal so that's how it's been managing
this for and I managed to save some too
I want to pay off with the debt yeah and
what do you make it here when you're
working when I was working I was because
I'm new here so I I was making only
about twenty five thousand a year going
back to that after the baby right I
don't know I want to know all right yeah
I have I have a background and I
actually have how long did you say you'd
been married five years okay all right
well what you're facing is probably not
that unusual overall and you're equating
it to necessarily your backgrounds and I
don't think that's what it is I think
it's just a breakdown in you do not have
shared goals and you do not have
communication over the subject of money
and the bottom line is that that's
terrifying you and I don't think you've
used that word I think you need to get
his I think you need to place your hands
on each side of his face and pull his
eyes next to yours and say this is
terrifying me this is terrifying me it's
creating deep anxiety and anxiety in me
that we will not work on this and you
will not work on this please for the
sake of our marriage for the sake of my
sanity please help me please and see
what kind of reaction that because this
did you're just having these glancing
blow drive-throughs drive-bys of
conversations rather than sitting down
having a deep conversation about how
this is affect
you because you're scared darling I hear
it in your voice and it's the avoidance
of conflict like we took a call similar
if you say well yeah but it's not
sometimes what I try to explain the
ladies is men I'm and I'm included in
this our thick
you cannot just give us we don't do
subtlety you just have to say it
he should know he doesn't know yeah why
doesn't he do this he look the fact that
you don't talk to me about this is
terrifying me it feels like it's a
weight over our heads and it's going to
come in and wash our whole house away
this is scaring me to death I can hear
it in your voice
and he's not hearing it and so one thing
Sharon and I learned when we're kind of
work on our marriage was that sometimes
something is attend to you and it's a
two to him and so this is a one to him
and a 12 to you and he you're you're
trying to communicate he's hearing a one
he's not hearing a 12 and you need to
change your language to pierce through
the thickness where he hears 12 fire
alarm fire alarm fire alarm this is a
problem it's not you griping it's I'm
scared because you are I hear it